[Musica]
[Applauso]
se oggi non capirete proprio tutto State
tranquilli È normale per la materia
fiscale un magma di norme che vengono
continuamente affastellate l'una
sull'altra decreti legge convertiti
inseguono decreti non convertiti leggi
delega perdono pezzi di decreti
legislativi decreti Mille proroghe legge
di bilancio sono approvati la notte di
San Silvestro fra i fuochi d'artificio
disordine rinvii termini paghi
confusione ma noi abbiamo un ancora di
salvezza un faro che ci illumina nella
notte procellosa della compilazione
della dichiarazione dei redditi la
Costituzione
e sul fisco la Costituzione dai numeri 2
la solidarietà 3 l'uguaglianza 23 la
riserva di legge 53 la capacità
contributiva e la progressività ma
iniziamo dai principi fondamentali
l'articolo 2 riguarda la solidarietà
garantire il benessere sociale e lo
scopo del diritto tributario il settore
tributario riunisce le regole in base
alle quali la ricchezza dei consociati
viene trasferita alle organizzazioni
pubbliche alle organizzazioni cioè alle
quali è di mandato il compito di fornire
servizi alla collettività sanità
istruzione e sicurezza difesa
tra contribuenti organizzazioni
pubbliche Esiste un rapporto di scambio
sui contribuenti incombe un dovere
inderogabile di solidarietà economica
sulle organizzazioni pubbliche invece
Grava il compito di garantire il
benessere della collettività
l'architettura del sistema tributario
fondamentale per la gestione della Polis
giusto in posizione giusto procedimento
giusto processo sono tre obiettivi e
devono essere perseguiti alla luce del
principio di uguaglianza articolo 3
uguaglianza
nel primo comma per uguaglianza formale
si intende l'uguaglianza di tutti
davanti alla legge sono Poi specificati
alcuni criteri che possono essere alla
base di discriminazioni il genere la
religione il secondo comma invece
sancisce l'uguaglianza sostanziale
affida allo stato il compito di crearne
le condizioni lo Stato cioè deve
eliminare le discriminazioni
intervenendo attivamente facciamo un
esempio
pensiamo a due ragazzini che vogliono
guardare oltre alla siepe Il primo è un
po' più alto della serie quindi non avrà
problemi Il secondo invece è un po' più
basso Come possiamo risolvere questo
problema in base al primo comma si
direbbe dando entrambi uno sgabello di
pari altezza
in base al secondo comma quindi
all'uguaglianza sostanziale noi dobbiamo
dare lo sgabello soltanto al ragazzino
più basso
tagliamo ora queste regole nel favoloso
mondo dei tributi con due esempi di
uguaglianza tributaria
nel bilancio di genere relativo al 2020
redatto dal Ministero dell'Economia e
delle Finanze si registra una differenza
del 20% fra l'occupazione femminile e
quella maschile
com'è possibile riequilibrare i ruoli
dell'uomo e della donna nel mondo del
lavoro
è una domanda complessa a una domanda
complessa bisogna dare una risposta
altrettanto complessa
uno degli strumenti che può essere
utilizzati insieme con altri e la leva
tributaria
con fine ultimo di promuovere
l'uguaglianza di genere si può ridurre
quindi la pressione fiscale sul lavoro
delle donne ad esempio l'aliquota sul
lavoro femminile potrebbe essere
inferiore rispetto a quella applicata al
lavoro maschile E questo a parità di
gettito complessivo
in realtà questa proposta nasce
dall'osservazione di alcune dinamiche
che caratterizzano la famiglia
tradizionale quella cioè composta da
marito moglie e figli alle donne viene
tradizionalmente attribuito il carico di
lavoro domestico e di lavoro di
accudimento dei figli e dei componenti
fragili del nucleo familiare
facendosi carico di un peso maggiore
nella gestione della famiglia le donne
tengono il freno tirato per quanto
riguarda la carriera lavorativa Ecco la
cosiddetta gender Tax la tassazione
differenziata per genere dovrebbe
incentivare l'occupazione femminile
agendo sull'offerta di lavoro dovrebbe
rendere economicamente più conveniente
per la famiglia nel suo insieme la
partecipazione della donna al mondo del
lavoro
nel 2019 il parlamento europeo ha
approvato una risoluzione sulla
Uguaglianza di genere e sulle politiche
fiscali nei vari paesi dell'Unione
europea fra le varie cose che sono state
scritte in questo documento di appunto
un richiamo alla necessità per gli Stati
membri di introdurre nelle imposte sui
redditi un trattamento differenziato in
ragione del genere
bianco una considerazione ulteriore che
riguarda le imposte sul consumo Infatti
il parlamento europeo ha constatato che
l'IVA esercita un pregiudizio di genere
perché il modello di consumo delle donne
è diverso rispetto a quello degli uomini
perché gli assorbenti sono tassati come
bene di lusso
sospetto che sia perché uomini
scrivevano le leggi quando sono state
introdotte queste imposte
questo scambio di battute è avvenuto nel
2016 fra una intervistatrice e l'allora
presidente degli Stati Uniti Barack
Obama trovate il video sul sito del Time
Perché pagare l'IVA sugli assorbenti
igienici con la stessa aliquota prevista
per i superalcolici
il ciclo mestruale non è un rosso
in Italia l'aliquota sugli assorbenti
igienici è stata abbassata dal 22 al 10%
con l'ultima legge di bilancio Ma veniva
richiesto l'azzeramento della cosiddetta
tampon Tax cioè l'azzeramento del carico
fiscale o almeno la riduzione della
aliquota al 4 al 5%. Come accade in
altri paesi dell'Unione Europea in
Irlanda l'imposizione su questi prodotti
è stata azzerata nel 2006 nel Regno
Unito nel 2021 in altri Stati
dell'Unione l'imposizione è più bassa
rispetto a quella Oggi prevista in
Italia
più di 15 milioni di donne in età
fertile usano assorbenti e prodotti
similari la riduzione l'azzeramento del
carico fiscale è una vittoria di
principio prima ancora che economica una
misura che normalizza la natura della
donna e la sua salute
se ci facciamo i conti in tasca possiamo
verificare sulla nostra pelle che 13
cicli l'anno per una durata media di 38
anni vogliono dire un onere economico
complessivo di circa 3.000 euro per
ciascuna donna nell'arco della propria
vita questo calcolo con l'IVA al 22%. se
un risparmio di 300 euro se l'aliquota
scenda 10 di 400 euro se la ditta scende
al 5 tanto è poco
Dipende dalle condizioni in cui versa
ciascuna donna
Non tutti possono permettersi un
abbonamento a un servizio di streaming
per un valore di 15 16 20 30 euro al
mese il ciclo mestruale però non è
intrattenimento non è un lusso non è
neppure una scelta è un processo
naturale che ci permette di generare la
vita
torniamo a dare i numeri
articolo 23 riserva di legge anche
l'articolo 23 da applicazione al
principio di uguaglianza nell'ambito
fiscale riserva di legge vuol dire che
le regole del gioco devono essere
delineate dal Parlamento cioè
dall'organo costituzionale al quale è
affidata la rappresentanza Democratica
della volontà Popolare
articolo 53 Capacità contributiva e
progressività Che cosa vuol dire
contribuire vuol dire dare insieme con
altri per un vantaggio comune
Capacità contributiva è sia un mezzo per
identificare ciò che deve essere tassato
In quale misura deve essere tassato ma è
anche una misura di garanzia
Capacità contributiva indica le
manifestazioni oggettive di ricchezza
cosa Tasso Tasso il reddito il
patrimonio il consumo Ma quanto Tasso
chi più ha più ha
la capacità contributiva però è anche
una tutela è un limite al dovere di
solidarietà sociale che Grava sui
singoli consociati
bilancia i diritti dei singoli con i
Diritti Sociali e il contraltare
dell'articolo 42 della Costituzione
quello che qualifica il diritto di
proprietà come diritto fondamentale ma
allo stesso tempo ammette che esso
subisca dei limiti
in favore
interesse collettivo principio di
uguaglianza declinato nella sua
dimensione di ragionevolezza e di non
arbitrarietà delle scelte legislative
l'articolo 53 è anche progressività i
tributi nel loro insieme devono essere
disegnati in maniera tale da gravare in
misura superiore chi più ha chi più
manifesta Capacità contributiva chi più
è ricco potremmo dire banalizzando
quindi questa seconda parte
dell'articolo 53 ci dice come Tasso
secondo criteri di progressività Ma
cos'è il soldoni la progressività
gli esperti di Fiscal Fusion potrebbero
utilizzare lapologo del Cucchiaio di
minestra
cucchiaio dopo cucchiaio diminuisce la
fame
e il piacere di gustare una pietanza
scendendo nel tecnico
una volta che siamo stati soddisfatti i
bisogni di base le quote più elevate di
ricchezza sono utilizzate per pagare
bisogni sempre meno essenziali E allora
è giusto che su queste quote più elevate
di ricchezza
vi sia un prelievo tributario più
gravoso
oggi nel nostro sistema l'attuazione del
principio dei progressività è affidata
all'irpef quella della dichiarazione dei
redditi per intenderci l'imposta sul
reddito delle persone fisiche negli anni
Settanta
esistevano 32 scaglioni di reddito 32
gradini
oggi ne sopravvivono soltanto 4
quindi possiamo constatare come questo
strumento attraverso il quale viene
perseguita l'uguaglianza abbia perso il
suo ruolo nelle scelte politiche che
sono state fatte negli ultimi anni la
curva che rappresenta la progressività
dell'irpef via via appiattita
articolo 97 buon andamento e
imparzialità dell'amministrazione anche
l'articolo 87 attua il principio di
uguaglianza
disegna un preciso obbligo per la
pubblica amministrazione di svolgere la
propria attività evitando ogni
discriminazione arbitrio nell'attuazione
dell'interesse pubblico
in parzialità si attua non soltanto sul
piano dell'organizzazione della
struttura amministrativa ma anche sul
piano dell'esercizio dell'attività
amministrativa
Il rispetto della fiducia creata nei
cittadini la lealtà dell'agire devono
connotare l'attività della pubblica
amministrazione di ogni sua ripartizione
Qualunque sia la peste che sa ad indossa
pubblica oppure per esempio di società
di diritto privato
giusto procedimento vuol dire
collaborazione fra contribuente
amministrazione vuol dire correttezza
buona fede vuol dire anche attuare il
contraddittorio con il privato prima
dell'emissione dell'atto il
contraddittorio è uno strumento
dell'istruttoria amministrativa che
viene utilizzata dalla pubblica
amministrazione nell'interesse del
privato perché gli consente di
difendersi prima
rispetto a quando sia necessario andare
in giudizio ma è anche uno strumento
utile nell'interesse pubblico perché
consenta l'amministrazione di acquisire
informazioni e quindi di agire con
Maggiore consapevolezza
questo strumento può addirittura portare
l'amministrazione a non emettere la
111 giusto processo giusto processo vuol
dire parità delle parti e giudice terzo
imparziale
e terzo imparziale il giudice tributario
e terzo imparziale un giudice che è
nominato da una delle due parti in
giudizio
che percepisce un compenso determinato e
liquidato da una delle due parti in
giudizio che ha assistito da personale
dei segreteria formato da dipendenti di
una delle due parti in giudizio che
utilizza i locali gli arredi le risorse
tecniche di una delle due parti in
giudizio No non è un giudice terzo e
imparziale
non si può affidare il rispetto di
questi principi alla buona volontà dei
singoli è necessario che l'ordinamento
della Giustizia tributaria sia
conformata ai Principi del giusto
processo quindi nella riforma che forse
verrà la luce in attuazione del Piano
Nazionale di ripresa e resilienza deve
essere interrotto ogni legame
organizzativo che lega i giudici
tributari al Ministero dell'Economia e
delle Finanze Sì perché era lui il terzo
incomodo in questo
9 tutela di culture ricerca paesaggio e
patrimonio storico artistico 24 tutela
dei diritti difesa dei non ambienti 32
tutela della Salute 34 tutela
dell'Istruzione 35 tutela del lavoro
tra il contribuente e la vita dello
Stato impositore vi è un legame
strettissimo vi è una identità di
interessi il tributo è fattore di
giustizia sociale questo lo diceva Ezio
Vanoni uno dei nostri padri costituenti
e Sandro Pertini uno dei nostri
Presidenti della Repubblica
affermava che non può esservi vera
Libertà senza giustizia sociale
si può considerare veramente libero un
uomo che ha fame che nella miseria che
non ha lavoro che umiliato perché non sa
come mantenere i suoi figli come
educarli questo non è un uomo libero
quest'uomo è libero soltanto di
bestemmiare di imprecare ma non è
libertà
oggi bisogna attuare una rivoluzione
copernicana passando dal dovere
tributario al diritto tributario cioè il
diritto che deve essere riconosciuto a
Ciascun associato di vedere garantito il
proprio benessere attraverso
l'erogazione di servizi alla comunità
servizi che siano finanziati mediante un
prelievo equo e attuato secondo
procedure giuste
la costituzione è importante
difendiamolo
[Applauso]